многие задаются вопросом каково это быть
неприлично богатым Почему важно
посмотреть это видео Дело в том что не
существует людей которые не хотели бы
стать богатыми которые не хотели бы
заработать денег Ну многие в том числе
возможно и вы а хотят заработать большие
деньги но Вы не представляете что вас
ждёт Давайте сегодня поговорим об этом
все люди думают что быть богатым очень
хорошо Ну конечно же потому что все люди
видят только внешнюю сторону машины дома
яхты самолёты и поэтому думаю что быть
богатым хорошо Сегодня я с вами поделюсь
вообще историями о том Каково на самом
деле быть богатым человеком и я поделюсь
с вами своей историей своим опытом и тем
ка какой ценой достаётся Богатство и вы
сами примете решение идти по этой
дорожке или нет проблема номер один в
том что с ростом благосостояния человека
жизнь начинает терять свои краски Дело в
том что богатые люди ощущают жизнь
по-другому современная наука доказала
что все наши ощущения физические и
эмоциональные они напрямую связаны с
гормонами гормоны вообще переводятся с
греческого языка как возбуждаю заставляю
действовать это такие вещества которые
выбрасываются в нашей в нашу кровь и
благодаря которым мы чувствуем а то
прилив энергии то энтузиазм то мотивацию
а то воодушевление вдохновение и так
далее так вот существует три основных
гормона А их называют ещё гормонами
радости или гормонами счастья первый
гормон - это серотонин Эндорфин и
Дофамин они три гормона похожие но
отвечают за разные функции и за разные
ощущения и А за разные чувства которые
вызываются у нас так вот проблема в том
что по мере роста вашего благо ся вы
начинаете проживать больше ярких событий
в своей жизни и тут такая засада чем
больше ярких событий в жизни вы
проживаете тем меньше у вас
чувствительность к гормонам радости и
проблема в том что вот например
когда богатый человек покупает очередной
Mercedes или rolls-royce он не радуется
так же как бедный или обычный человек
который купил свою первую Ладу Приору
вспомните например свою первую покупку
наверняка Она на вас произвела огромное
впечатление и вызвала бурю эмоций кстати
Поделитесь в комментариях о своей первой
покупки и что вы испытывали в этот
момент я например сам помню когда В
девяносто первом году я только женился
это был ноябрь месяц и старший брат мне
подарил Ладу Жигули 007 не 007 семёрка
тогда мы назвали и это она была
бордового цвета И это была для меня прям
такая радость такое А такие яркие эмоции
Я как раз женился 8 ноября и брат
подарил мне эту машину так вот я ночевал
в ней а и молодожён и ночевал в ней
потому что у меня не было гаража для
меня Настолько эта машина была дорогой
но в то же время эта машина у меня была
только до Нового года её разбили в
дребезги и в отдельном видео я расскажу
почему нельзя сильно любить вещи вторая
большая проблема - Это то что у богатых
людей снижается чувствительность к
гормонам и это вторая большая проблема
потому что смотрите у него меньше
выбрасываются гормоны так ещё и
гормональная система она
чувствительность гормоном понижается
таким образом богатые люди не чувствуют
той радости От тех приобретений и той
жизни которой они которой они живут
какой из этого можно сделать вывод хоть
богатые люди и могут себе позволить
больше но на самом деле у них от этого
удовольствие больше не становится если
взять за мерило
богатства то удовольствие которое
получает человек от приобретения или
чего-то или образа жизни то можно
увидеть такую прямую корреляцию что чем
больше у человека богатства тем дороже
ему обходится удовольствие тем дороже
ему обходится то ощущение счастья и
радости которая доступна обычному
человеку цена удовольствия и ощущаемой
радости растёт прямо пропорционально
росту вашего благосостояния Если вы
хотите получить больше радости и больше
удовольствия то вам придётся тратить
гораздо больше денег и это основная
проблема богатых людей от которых ещё
никто не нашёл противоядие А расскажите
а то есть получается вся реклама которую
мы видим где счастливые обеспеченные
люди катаются на роллс-ройса летают на
личных Джета везде счастливые лица и нам
продают это как образ счастья вот купи
Вот что-то нужное часы машину отпуск и
будет счастье и Это всё обман не на
самом деле весь маркетинг построен на
двух основных инструментах первый
инструмент - это это Соблазн второй
инструмент - это страх соответственно
для того если вы хотите чтобы люди а
захотели что-то у вас купить то это
обязательно показать яркую красивую
картинку что и делают все маркетологи А
если они будут показывать обратную
сторону то понятно что никто не хочет э
этого достичь и никто не захочет этого
покупать поэтому это обычный
маркетинговый приём Ну а люди клюют
именно на это на яркую красивую картинку
потому что снимать обратную сторону я
наверняка уверен не не всем интересно и
наверное многим людям будет неинтересно
смотреть обратную сторону потому что
если брать в целом богатство А то ведь
на самом деле мы видим яркую картину
Конечный результат но мы не видим
ежедневную пахоту работу концентрацию ту
ответственность которую на себя берёт
каждый богатый человек и поэтому людям
показывают то что они хотят видеть
основная проблема в этом а не то что на
самом деле происходит Можно ли научить
себя захотеть видеть правду смотрите это
не вопрос того чтобы научить себя
захотеть видеть правду а вопрос ваших
внутренних убеждений если у вас в голове
стоят правильные убеждения то вы всегда
можете распознать и увидеть за внешней
красивой картинкой реальную картину и
ситуацию вы всегда будете видеть за
яркой красивой картинкой тяжёлый труд и
это не смотрите у людей у которых
правильные убеждения и правильное
понимание
А на них не работает яркая картинка они
не соблазняют потому что они понимают
что за этим стоит более того чем ярче и
красивее картинка тем больше труда стоит
за этой картинкой И это люди у которых
правильные убеждения Они понимают сразу
кстати об убеждениях богатых людей и
особенно супер богатых людей я сделаю
отдельное видео поэтому Подпишите
следите за моими выпусками вторая
проблема которая не позволяет богатым
людям наслаждаться своим богатством это
тяжёлая ответственность которую они
осознают некоторые даже не осознают
наверное но вернее так они
подсознательно всё равно осознают и это
на них давит все люди хотят денег а
почему они их хотят потому что в
сознании всех людей деньги ассоциируются
со свободой любая Свобода Что такое
свобода
и для чего она нам нужна Свобода даёт
нам пространство возможности И именно
поэтому она нам нами ценится а
пространство возможностей это всегда
неизвестность это всегда риски есть
такое правило чем больше рисков тем
больше проблем А если риски большие то и
проблемы большие а проблемы всегда
приводят к ответственности и именно это
наша подсознание чётко понимает и
осознаёт таким образом Вы даже можете
сами не чувствовать своим мозгом
но Ваше подсознание это чувствует И
когда многие из вас хотят заработать
денег ваше подсознание говорит А зачем
нам это нужно зачем нам нужна
дополнительная ответственность и это
основная причина того что многие из вас
не достигают своих целей потому что у
вас нету согласия между вашим мозгом и
рациональным и вашим подсознанием они
как лебед рак и щука тянут в разные
стороны я сам помню когда я был очень
супер человеком А я хоть и имел яхты
самолёты вертолёты и так далее но я
всегда чувствовал что меня всегда могут
вызвать а там в администрацию президента
в Правительство Я каждый день боялся
чтобы не произо не произошло что-то на
моих предприятиях какая-то авария
какое-то ЧП и так далее и так далее
таким образом вот эта ответственность
всегда отправляла те удовольствия
которые я получил от своего получал от
своего статуса психологические точки
зрения богатство - это ощущение полной
своей экономической безопасности когда
люди имеют богатство в народе даже
говорят что такой человек как бы
всемогущий он может всё он может себе
позволить всё но на самом деле не все
понимают глубину этой фразы когда люди
имеют в виду всемогущество они
подразумевает что этот человек может
себе позволить Всё потому что у него
много денег а я рас
фу немного по-другому когда богатый
человек всемогущий это значит у него
много возможностей и мало
ответственности и это большая и Ключевая
разница Дело в том что само
богатство в обыденном понимании
измеряется количеством денег или активов
и так далее но на самом деле если брать
на наше внутренне ощущение я могу
сказать Из своего опыта который я
пережил на самом деле Ино богатство
ощущение богатства приходит от разницы
между вашими возможностями и вашей
ответственностью не сумма денег Если у
вас условно 10 млрд долларов и у вас
ответственности на 10 млрд долларов То
вы не будете ощущать себя богатым
человеком Вы больше будете ощущать
ответственность неже нежели удовольствие
А если у вас там активов на 100 млн
долларов и при этом ответственности на
10 Поверьте мне у вас ощущение богатство
будет гораздо лучше гораздо ярче вы
будете это чувствовать и радоваться
отсюда возникает следующий Вывод что
получается Если богатство никак не
связано с количеством денег то каждый
человек может почувствовать себя богатым
и это правда Работайте над увеличением
своих возможностей ведь не даром в
народе говорят Не имей 100 руб имей 100
друзей Что это значит это не про деньги
а это про возможности Когда у вас 100
друзей у вас больше возможной и это вам
даёт ощущение богатства поэтому
развивайте свои возможности каждый
человек может стать богатым не каждый
человек может накопить огромное
количество денег и активов Но каждый
человек может почувствовать себя богатым
и наращивать свои возможности и всё
время Работайте над сокращением своей
ответственности я не призываю вас здесь
к безответственности Я призываю вас к
тому чтобы на вас не накладывала
ответственность поэтому вовремя и
аккуратно выполняйте свои обязательства
не берите в долг Приходите на встречи
вовремя не
попадайтесь люди интуитивно понимают
разницу между большим количеством денег
и настоящим богатством прежде всего
настоящее богатство оно ощущается через
лёгкость Вы наверное сами в своей жизни
наверняка сталкивались со своим первыми
заработками вспомните Когда вы
зарабатывали деньги с тяжёлым трудом и
как они вам давались и вспомните
Наверняка у вас бывали моменты когда
некоторые деньги у вас получилось
зарабатывать легко если у вас было такое
ощущение Поставьте лайк и мы продолжим
дальше Поэтому если вы будете выполнять
все свои обязательства аккуратно думать
прежде чем что-то кому-то обещать а если
пообещали выполнять Ну есть целый
комплекс действий которые делать чтобы
ВС время понижать свою ответственность
то Поверьте мне даже имея в активах там
100.000 долларов вы будете ощущать себя
богатым человеком и это связано
подчеркну с вашими возможностями и вашей
ответственностью а
именно с разницей между вашими
возможностями и вашей ответственностью я
понимаю то что я сейчас вам рассказал
увеличение своих возможностей и
уменьшение своей
ответственности непростая задача для
этого требуются определённые знания
навыки и Именно для этого я веду свой
Telegram канал который я веду лично и я
даю там различные свои приёмы лайфхаки и
то как действовать для того чтобы всё
время иметь огромное пространство
возможностей и при этом сокращать зону
своей ответственности ссылку на свой
Telegram канал я оставляю здесь под этим
видео если интересно переходите прямо
сейчас проблема номер
три все люди смотрят на как на источник
денег и вы теряете ощущение жизни Дело в
том что по мере роста вашего
благосостояния и По мере того как вы
становитесь богатым человеком каждый
человек хочет от вас что-то получить в
результате вы перестаёте видеть Истинное
лицо людей и вы не понимаете кто враг А
кто друг вы не понимаете реально кто
достоин кто недостоин и так далее и
сопутствующая к этому проблема состоит в
том что вы начинаете терять ощущение
жизни почему это происходит и к чему это
приводит это приводит к тому что богатые
люди начинают сторониться людей они
становятся более циничным у них
появляется определённая черствость и
пропадает чувствительность к нуждам
заботам или бедам людей это не из-за
того что они жадные А из-за того что
очень много людей у них что-то просят И
очень многие из них просят не на
настоящую проблему они не по-настоящему
нужда
на самом деле богатые люди они как бы
живут в этой оболочке обмана и в
результате когда к ним обращаются
реально нуждающиеся люди Они зачастую
отказывают люди со стороны думают что
они просто жадные на самом деле богатые
люди становятся более циничным и они
предпочитают одиночество чем общение с
другими людьми А это приводит к ещё
одной проблеме
из-за вот этого ореола обмана который
находится вокруг богатого человека
богатые люди начинают терять
ощущения реальности они не получают
реальную правдивую обратную связь от
этого мира а отсутствие реальной
обратной связи приводит к ошибкам в
принятии решений и эти ошибки в принятии
решений приводят к потере этого
богатства помимо этого богатые люди
теряют мотивацию у них пропадает желание
что-либо делать Ну за исключением
конечно некоторых богатых людей которые
изначально лились не на богатство
которые изначально Уч занимались любимым
делом Именно поэтому я постоянно
призываю с самого начала когда начинаете
заниматься бизнесом сначала выбрать
любимое дело а потом топить в этом деле
всю жизнь И это дело скорее приведёт вас
к богатству и когда вы станете богатым
человеком вы не столкнётся
обеспеченный человек очень богатый
человек не миллиардер ещё но почти у
него все тылы
закрыты денег хватает Бизнес растёт и
вот меня поразила его фраза когда я ему
сказал А в чём твой запрос в чём Твоя
боль он говорит при идеальной жизни и
благополучии Я каждый день думаю о
самоубийстве и это именно тот случай
когда о которых я сегодня вам говорил
какой можно из этого всего сделать вывод
из этого нужно сделать Я считаю такие
выводы и я это говорю исходя из своего
жизненного опыта так как у меня были все
игрушки богатого человека Я через всё
это проходил Я всё это ощущал самое
главное вам нужно понимать такую вещь
как в исламе говорится держите деньги в
кулаке на расстоянии вытянутой руки Что
это значит Это значит не подпускать и не
запускать деньги в сердце держать их в в
кулаке и не расслаблять свой кулак Вот
это оптимальное соотношение и
оптимальное отношение к деньгам деньги
Вы должны помнить сами по себе не
приносят счастья но они помогают
пережить несчастье и ещё одна фраза
которой я хотел бы закончить этот выпуск
деньги не могут вам купить любимые вещи
но они помогут вам купить время для того
чтобы вам заниматься любимым делом